get get out of here fly this is the
wrong time
hi i'm kevin hart sexist man alive and
these are my essentials
i love a very hectic lifestyle always on
the go and there's certain things that i
need
to make that go as goalie as possible
my first thing is my runner's hat and
this is a dry fit
nike head i love the run i exercise
every day
all day i never miss a day ever
unless i don't have my hat then i miss a
day when i run in gyms
i get a lot of people to try to stare at
my butt that's why i start going outside
i used to turn around that would be crap
quite the crowd behind me
you people need to move on this is what
i would say
and they would say
he wouldn't say anything because that
never happened i just i'd like to be
outside
this right here is my trusty charger you
know i'm on my phone a lot
i found that because i use my phone so
much
my battery is always on the low you know
when it comes to talking about
my projects my managers and agents those
are long conversations because we got so
much that we're doing by time we're
running down that list
my phone is dead so i need a little
juice
i had this charger since i was six since
i was six years old
a friend of mine actually invented these
chargers and i've been testing it
for the last 33 years yeah
oh i call this sunshine okay
this is this is my skin care product
fellas message to you
don't be afraid to take care of your
skin take care of that skin
you always gotta stumble upon what works
for you some things you think work
don't work i'm what you would call a
product junkie i didn't been through a
load of product there was one product i
was using that had me looking
like an extra and a walking dead i was
dry as hell
then i was using baby oil on my face
that wasn't cool
looked like i was always ready to fight
and then this recommendation came to me
i was walking in the department store
and some lady just put it on me
this lady was like thinner and she just
put it on my face
this lady was like glow
ah
and i rubbed it and i fell in love with
it and she was like you'll thank me
later
and i did here's the good stuff
now i need my deep blue this is what i
put on my joints
i'm getting older so my my body hurts
sometimes
my knees are cracking and my ankles get
the cracking
hear that hear that
i'm like a little black version of the
tin man this is my oil
it really is good for just your joints
and and muscles so
deep blue this
is my grease as you can tell i have very
curly hair
i've been called janet jackson in my
prime
i can do whatever i want with this you
know you want to see a mohawk you want
to see a bob
you want to see a little bang coming
down my face
i can do it all so when y'all see me out
there
and you see this here bouncing all over
the place like that
know that this is what's holding it in
place my shea
moisture curl enhancer smoothie thank
you shae
yeah here it comes my pots
yep my day to days my little
communicators
what happens with these things is
they're so light people don't know where
you're talking to
because i forgot they're in but they
stay they never move look
this is what i like the most about me
look at this
see they don't come out amazing to me
i love you you gotta have your favorite
pair of glasses
these are my tom brown glasses right
here you know what i call these
i call these my deal closers i don't
talk turkey
i talk business are you here to waste my
time are you here to finalize the deal
excuse me what did you say
that's what i thought i'll do it okay i
was in cool mode i'm sorry
ladies you might want to brace
yourselves
these are my underwear oops did i wear
these that cup in the front is pretty
big
are these dirty
i think i gave you guys the wrong pair
if you look down here you notice they
say kevin hart
i'm not just like an ambassador i'm an
investor this is a product that i have
owned
the most comfortable underwear on the
planet quality
and comfort at its best light very soft
and just you know comfortable
my biggest problem with other underwear
is i was always digging in my ass
for some reason underwear was always
stuck in my ass so i needed something
that wasn't gonna be in my ass
i wanted the no wedgie guarantee and
that's what i get from tommy john
i never dig in my butt with these ever
ever and this little pouch let me tell
you something i don't care what size you
are
you're going to be happy with the way it
looks when you put them on i found
myself very impressed with myself from a
visual standpoint when i got in front of
the mirror
so um these are my favorite i need to
take these
everywhere i go well you know i think
after letting you guys
inside you guys get to see that i'm a
well-groomed
individual you know these are things
that
help me maintain my look i'm responsible
for making people feel happy
i can't do that if my face look crazy
dragon and there's bags and stuff under
my eyes
if my hair isn't as curly as it is if
i'm digging in my
ass on a regular basis how are you going
to be happy when you see me
these are the things that allow me to
put a smile on your face and those
are my essentials hopefully you walk
away as excited as i
am i'm talking about from seeing my
bulge